as we have a 2022 Honda CRV customer
wanted us to program their second key to
their vehicle so we're going to go to
immo we're going to go to
Honda we're going to go to manual
selection we're going to go to
CRV smart
key push to start
yes we're just going to read and scan
the vehicle make sure everything is
working fine before we start and uh we
do the same afterwards just to make sure
you
know nothing was done on our end
everything looks normal it says a total
of two smart keys in the system
afterwards there's going to be three
because we're going to be adding this
we're going to do add a key
start the vehicle is currently on
there's no
dtc's we'll say
okay turn the ignition
off so we're going to take our learn key
right here we're going to leave it in
the vehicle we're going to take our
other key leave it outside all right key
is outside turn the ignition
on hit it
[Music]
twice perfect the key has been added to
the vehicle we're going to go ahead and
say we want to program another
key we're going to take everything out
of the vehicle let's say okay everything
is
out now we'll take our new key got our
new key inside the
vehicle we're going to say
okay key has successfully been added
we'll say okay
we'll turn the ignition
off turn the ignition on and now it's
just going through the cycle it's the
same cycle when you have a bladed
key the mobilizer light is no longer
on we'll say
yes when you have a bladed key you're
just instead of turn pushing a button
all you're doing is turning it off
turning it on turning it
[Music]
off registration is
complete turn that
off you want to check that everything
works we'll just test this one out we'll
see it locks and unlocks the door so we
know it's working
and we'll go and turn that on
again now you see it changed from two
keys to three keys so we're all
set once again we'll scan the system
just make sure everything's working
properly once we're all
done all right we're going to go to emo
status scan ignition is turned on
on everything is normal so we know the
key been programmed and there's no
issues in the vehicle
so we have a success in
programming 2022 Honda
CRV adding the key and we'll show you
that it starts the vehicle as well
here you go key has started the
vehicle thank you so much for watching
2022 Honda CRV adding a key we're going
to go ahead and cut the blade key for
them now and uh give the customer back
their keys